that was your one moment I told you
about my one moment against dirt that's
your one moment this one moment can
Define where you go from
here now that moment might not mean as
much to Jason t as it means to
you you fight for your [__] life In
This Moment he playing he wants it but
he not fighting for his life it's a
different approach now mind you we got
nine [__] fighting for their
life four of them [__] is
making 800 million and the other four
making 100,000 fighting for their life
now you eight [__] that's
fighting for their life in the
[__]
ring and you wonder why we
[Music]
win Donis hm we are in Miami welcome and
I'm with the mayor welcome welcome we've
been waiting for you hey absolutely I'm
happy to be here it's a beautiful day I
mean you cannot say a bad thing about
Miami no it's a good day today it ain't
too hot you know what I'm saying we're
chilling today no I'm very happy to be
here happy to talk to you I have really
been looking forward to this because
there are so few people that have the
knowledge and experience that you have
in this league and you're such a
principled person and I don't think a
lot of people are principled and one of
my favorite shows is the wire and in it
he says a man got to have a code yes and
you absolutely have a code yes ma'am I
do what are these what are three things
that you live
by oh
man well I mean for me I got to be able
to look myself in the mirror you know
what I'm saying when it's a tough
decision for me to make I get on the
right side of it I Manan make it easy
for myself what's the right thing to do
you know what I'm saying and um you know
thirdly is I just got to keep it real
you know what I'm saying at all times no
matter what the circumstances no matter
whether it benefits me or it benefits
somebody else no no matter what the
outcome is like I just got to be to
sleep or not I got to be able to keep it
real with myself so I got to keep it
real with myself first man and losing
sleep at night is something that I ain't
willing to do not at this stage of the
game I'm tired of that ain't no more
losing sleep that's it so when did you
make that decision when were you losing
a lot of sleep I mean it was kind of I
was raised like this man I was raised
like kind of do the right things keep it
real with people around you keep it real
with yourself um and I
think trying to be liked you know what
I'm saying in a world where it's not
very nice out here I think that's the
last thing you can do you know what I'm
saying I think you got to be yourself
you got to live your truth you got to
walk your path you know what I'm saying
and I think for me you know what I've
noticed is that if I would have tried to
do it the way people wanted me to do it
if I would have tried to be liked on the
way to doing it then I'm not sitting
here having this conversation with you
today you know what I'm saying if I let
what people thought about me dictate my
circumstances if I let what people
thought I should be doing dictate where
I go then I don't go where I need to go
and I don't get where I'm trying to be
you know what I'm saying so you know for
me it's always about keeping a real with
myself and how I feel about the
decisions that I make CU I'm the one
that got to live with them I'm the one
that's got to suffer the circumstances
or if it doesn't go the way I want you
know what I'm saying so always just just
judging myself on am I keeping it real
with myself man am I am I am I going to
look myself in the mirror at night and
say you know what I'm saying you did the
right thing and you stood don't
something so that's what I always try to
do it's interesting how you talk about
you know not always wanting to be liked
or feeling that need to be liked because
you are so liked no no now yeah now and
it's because of the knowledge that I
have it's because I've been around it's
because of the success I play with the
greats you know what I'm saying I don't
take nothing away from the people that
I've had the opportunity to learn from
you know I'm saying all the way going
back to the shacks and you know I'm
saying the the the Alonzo mornings and
then I've had the chance to play with
the dway and you know the LeBron and the
Chris B so I've had a abundance of
knowledge that has come my way so um as
I've gotten to the OG rle and I don't
play that much no more I'm not as
competitive I think people make it's
maybe more approachable you know what
I'm saying from the next generation so
with DM and social media anybody can
reach out to anybody so it be surprised
and i' be surprised how many these young
guys reach out to me just for advice
just on not always basketball on
business on life on family you know what
I'm saying how to move out here and
um it's made me a little bit more
likable out here so I'm cool with that
because I'm a likable guy I got I got a
lot of like likable quality absolutely
yeah I'm just a competitor you know what
I'm saying people just see the
competitor most of the time so what
Vision did you have for yourself in the
NBA and then how did the reality of what
you were in the NBA live up to that
Vision man be honest I think when people
talk about their journey and their
vision and they was like oh I always
knew I was going to make it I I saw this
house I was going to buy my mom one day
nah I ain't know I was going to make it
I didn't have this vision of oh I'm G
buy this I'm gon do this I really just
kept my head down and worked every day
like okay how far can I go with this if
I keep if I keep pushing how good can I
be okay I got to the state championship
I was great in high school okay I got a
college scholarship how good can I be in
college you know what I'm saying can I
can I really push this you know I'm
saying to another level I was pretty
good in college but I wasn't drafted you
know what I'm saying so now there's a
decision to make and I could have sat
there and pointed the finger at the
teams that didn't draft me or I just
look at myself and say what can I do
better had to condition myself had to
get myself in better shape I wasn't in
the shape that I needed to be to put
myself in a position to be on an NBA
roster you know what I'm saying so um
that's another time I had to keep it
real myself you know what I'm saying not
pointing the finger at the league saying
oh they should have did this look who
they drafted nah I could do this what
can I do better that's another thing I
tell my young boys accountability you
know what I'm saying we'll get into that
later CU that's a foreign language these
days 100% yeah but I mean just just my
journey and my path um was never
scripted and I never knew where I was
going to be so I just put my head down
and work work work work work and once I
achieve something I said okay I could do
something else you know what I'm saying
that's where the confidence came to get
to where I'm at now CU I was just
achieving goals and I was like okay if I
put my head down if I work my ass off
can I say absolutely my ass off if I
work my ass off then how far can I go
man so it was just built off work
everything is built off the work don't
trust me trust the work I do want to
touch on what you said because it's an
important point about accountability
where do you think and why do you think
accountability has gotten a little lost
um probably selfishness you know what
I'm saying in in a way I think um I mean
we all born selfish and I think we have
to learn how to get out of that and I
think it's probably not you know the
generation per se got to give a sh I got
to got I got to I got to say it's the
parents gotta say as the parents man I
gotta say as the parents man if your kid
don't know accountability it's not it's
not your kid fault you know what I'm
saying if your kid don't know yes yes
ma'am no ma'am if your kid don't know
please thank you it's not your kids's
fault so I think with this generation if
they don't know accountability by the
time they get to 19 20 years old and
they making all this money it ain't just
happened now that mean they been a noed
you are who you are you are who you are
I mean you been wasn't taught that so
you know and that's a lot of the
situations with a lot of these kids that
come into this situation where they got
a lot of money and things like that
things have been given to them and it's
never really been their their job to be
accountable it's that's been their job
to just be good just be great and just
play the game and flourish you know what
I'm saying and then when you get to this
level there a lot of other things that
come with this money so with just all
this knowledge right what has been more
rewarding for you being a player or
being a mentor
ah
probably being a mentor really what I'm
saying being a mentor yeah because you
affect way so many more people when you
a mentor you know what I'm saying I was
watched so many so many guys come in
this organization first of all you talk
about the success we have with just
undrafted players you know what I'm
saying and I'm an undrafted guy I wear
that repr Pride so you know what I'm
saying like when these guys like come in
here I let them know like you're
expected to
be there's no drop off I don't care if
he was drafted first I don't care if he
got 100 Mil milon there's no drop off
you expected to do and go and play and
be just as successful as he is there
there's no drop off so the expectation
when you walk in locker room of a
undrafted player um I put even more on
you than a guy that was drafted you know
what I mean when these guys come in here
and it's personal you know what I'm
saying it's personal I live through
these guys when they walk in this locker
room okay I'm not playing I'm sitting on
the side but I'mma tell you exactly what
I would would do I'm going show you
exactly how you should do it and I
expect the results that I know you
should have if you do it I tell you to
do it and if you don't get those results
we going to keep going till we get
them what's your relationship with
ego with who ego ego
oh at this stage I have none I used to I
used to have a big ego yeah I used to
have a huge ego um but at this stage at
43 years old yeah and I understand that
you know um I've had my success as a
basketball player and um right now it's
not about about me you know what I'm
saying it's about van Mao it's about
Tyler hero it's about Jimmy Butler it's
about Jamal Kane undrafted it's about
Caleb Martin undrafted it's about guys
like Max stru who just got signed to a
big contract for Cleveland it's about
guys like gab Vincent who just got
signed for a big contract with the
Lakers you know what I'm saying it's
about Hassan Whiteside who was you know
what I'm saying out of the league and
came with Miami and got a max deal so I
could go on and on so it ain't about me
you know what I'm saying I I left me out
a long time ago it's been about them um
it's it's been about how can I impact
the Next Generation and help them Reach
their goals and where they trying to get
to because I see some of myself and so
many of these guys in in different
situations and different generations and
once again we bring in the most
undrafted players in the league you know
what I'm saying it's really hard to not
have ego though they think in a lot of
ways you know but I had it I had it I I
don't say I never had it I just don't
have it now now when I got into the Ro
where I wasn't playing as much and when
things start to turn the corner yeah it
was some dark nights yeah you throwing
[__] at the wall you mad you asleep you
want you know what I'm saying you come
to practice with a chip on your shoulder
you know what I'm saying so yeah
definitely I had ego but I mean okay who
cares who cares who cares that you D got
in his feelings today who cares the
world gonna stop the practice gonna stop
is SPO gonna stop is the heat GNA stop
hell no they not
so figure out how to be a part of it how
to be a asset or your liability which
one you want to
be but what was that big ego moment that
led to the realization that you now have
when I just realized
that there I mean to go home at night
and to take the frustration of being in
the gym and you know the things that
happen in the gym and take that home
with you it's not fair to you
kids it's not fair to your family it's
not fair to the people that sacrific for
you to be a to be in the position that
you're in so when I got to the point
where things that are frustrating with
work start to affect at home gota let
that [__] go gota Let it go you know
what I'm saying and that's probably
where decisions had to be made because
that up to that point yeah man I go home
at night if I ain't play well or if I
ain't get the minutes I want or
something I sit in the dog cut the
lights out don't bother me I talk to
y'all tomorrow but when you get to that
point and you start to realize that
ain't healthy for you and definitely not
healthy for the people around you that's
when you got to make changes on that you
know that's something I feel like
actually is not talked about a lot in
the league that being an NBA player is
such an all-encompassing job it's such a
a lifestyle something that consumes so
many parts of you that you almost it's
almost impossible to not bring work home
but bringing work home means that people
who are not involved are being burdened
by what happened with things that had
nothing to do with them and it sounds
like you're saying you were experiencing
that at some aspects of your life at
some point yeah I close off I mean I
felt no shame why should I yeah I gota I
got to be my best version out here on
the basketball court if I ain't playing
well then I ain't getting paid if I
ain't getting paid the bills ain't
getting paid so if I need to take two
days not to be bothered then leave me
alone but I think as you get to a point
where you get older like I said you
realize it's not about you man you know
what I'm saying like you got kids you
got a wife you got a mother you know
what I'm saying I lost my mother 12
years ago I just lost my father about
two and a half years ago you know what
I'm saying and you realize that you know
this time with these people are precious
you know what I'm saying and you don't
get these moments back and I think when
you get to a certain moment in life you
realize that things that really have
value are really just the memories you
know what I'm saying I sat in the I sat
in the hospital room with my mother at
one point and all we had were memories
yeah it didn't I couldn't pay for
nothing you know what I'm saying I
couldn't pay the doctors to do nothing I
couldn't pay for no special medicine you
know what I'm saying the same thing with
my my Pops I watch my pops and there's
no special medicine I can buy no matter
how much success I had no matter how
much Fame Udonis hasm has the memories
is what you got at them point so for me
realizing creating as many memories as I
can with the people I love and the
people around me that's why I try to
start to find True Value I had to let
that other [__] go like that's the true
currency and we've kind of been tricked
into thinking it's the other stuff yeah
but you got to find it the hard way
sometimes sometimes you got to go
through things to find out what the real
value in life and and where the real
value is MHM you know I always think you
some people they make fun of yic how all
he want to do is play basketball then go
home and he's like this is a job I want
to go home I want to do all these things
but he might be doing it right he is
doing it right he's doing it right he's
like this is the job you know and I
don't know it's everything else has made
us believe that yic has to care so
deeply about it in a way that we
actually should all be acting the way
yic is one of the best years I had was
the year that my mother mother was
really struggling you know fighting her
cancer and um I was coming I was
struggling with coming off the bench
that was the year that we had drafted
Michael Beasley obviously number two
pick hell of a player coming out of
college um in politics coming to play a
lot of things coming to play and Michael
Beasley end up being a starting power
forward for the Miami Heat supported
bees got much love for bees bees played
for um Frank Martin Frank Martin was my
high school coach at Miami High so as
soon as we drafted bees Coach Frank
reached out make sure you take care of
bees bees Locker was right next to mine
so bees was my guy but but obviously
there's a transition bees becomes a
starter I become the guy that comes off
the bench now throughout that transition
also my mother is sick as well so I'm
literally Landing from road trips and
I'm landing as soon as we land I'm going
to spend time with my mother in the
hospital um and just as much time as I
can ironically basketball was just a
sport it wasn't about life at that point
and my mother was more important there
was so many other things that was more
important I end up having one of the
better years I had I end up leading the
league and double doubles Off the Bench
um I was like runner up for six man of
the year and it was just one of the
more one of the better years that I had
but it was really because I really
didn't give a damn that much about
basketball was crazy like I was playing
well because basketball really wasn't my
priority at that time of my life and I
ended up playing way better and I
learned something at that point as well
in my life about you know just how I
approach the game and just how there's
so many more things that are more
important you know you've you've talked
about your mom before you talked about
your dad I was listening to the
interview that you did with the pivot
and in it you were talking about just
losses that you have endured in your
life and I think you said that when you
were going through the losses your
mindset was always sort of okay you keep
going you go to work we're taught that
you just are always pushing forward you
have now realized that that isn't always
the way to do it do you feel like you
have actually had a moment to cope with
what loss has been for you in your life
uh I'm still cope
still talking to my therapist still yeah
I'm still coping I'm still talking to my
therapist shout out to them you know who
you are um now I'm still coping man you
know what I'm saying like I said I lost
my mom 12 years ago my pops two and a
half years ago um I lost my old brother
Sam um you know I've I've dealt with a
lot of things so nah you I'm dealing
with them every day because I still miss
him I still think about them you know
what I'm saying I still think about what
my pops would have said when I sit down
and watch the dolphin games on Sunday
because that's what we used to do you
know what I'm saying um when I go to
church on Sunday I still think about my
mom's CU she was real religious you know
what I'm saying so n I'm still coping
every day but they live through me you
know what I'm saying I got a highight
team never been to a highight match only
reason I bought a highight team because
I remember when I was a kid my mom and
daddy used to go to highight and leave
me in the car because I couldn't go in
and they say I'll be back in about an
hour they go in they play their little
highly they win their money or not and
they come back and we go home buy our
business and go home so for me having an
opportunity to buy a H Team when I was
older it's just living through my
parents living through me you know what
I'm saying and I've learned the game and
it's exciting as hell but I just
remember those M most moments when my PO
he boy I'll be right back don't don't
open this door I'mma crack these windows
don't go nowhere and he come back he be
where he went his little money we go eat
somewhere if he ain't with his little
money we take her home go home
on you know what I'm saying so they have
the opportunity to do something like
that that's my parents living through me
it's beautiful cuz you I'm sure they are
absolutely living through you what is um
what's a personality trait that you got
from your mom and one you got from your
dad oh man personality trait my probably
um I'm I'm funny I'm like I'm like funny
I got jokes I got that from my mama my
mama my mama got jokes I got that from
my mama um from my
daddy you can't tell me and ain't
nothing I can't
do I'm telling you you can't tell me and
a if I ain't do it I'm GNA learn how to
do it you know what I'm saying I'm never
gonna tell you that you can beat me in
nothing I'm never gonna tell you that
you're better than me at nothing you
know what I'm saying I I believe I can
do everything I got a son that play
baseball I ain't never played baseball a
day in my life but I would not let him
think he can strike me out
ever I would not let him think he's ever
gonna be able to strike me out you know
what I'm saying so I'm just that I got
that from my daddy for sure cuz there
wasn't a day that my daddy ever let me
think I was going to be him anything
that's beautiful and I I really love
hearing that you're in therapy and
you're coping you're doing all the
things say this every show we talk about
therapy a lot I have a therapist she's
great shout out Dr Dell everybody should
absolutely TR um I was also reading an
interview that you did with I think it
was hot living and you said I couldn't
have dreamed it any better which is why
I think I didn't dream what did you mean
by that see I just said that earlier
remember I said I didn't plan this
yeah because when you walk out your
house every day and you see something
it's hard to dream other than what you
see I had never been to South Beach
until I got in the NBA I tell people all
the time so how the hell was I gonna
dream about going over there if I don't
even know what's over there you know
what I'm saying until I got to the till
I got the University of Florida I
thought everybody lived like me when I
get oh wait a minute you didn't see
drugs growing up you didn't see violence
you didn't see this you didn't see that
then I started to realize that things I
experienc was different they wasn't the
ones different it was me that was
different like I experienced the trauma
like I thought that my life was normal
hell no my [__] was not normal and I was
looking at them like the hell kind of
life you had then I realized like it was
the me that had experienced the Trum in
life and it was me that was going
through the the the negative things so N
I didn't dream man it wasn't until I got
to college until I played the University
of Florida I realized that I grew up a
little different you know what I'm
saying and that's when I probably
started to realize okay there's other
things out here for me and that's why I
make it my mission now with my
Foundation is first things first let's
show them something different than what
they see every day because they GNA be
brainwashed by what they see every day
and that makes it 10 times harder to get
him out the mud you need the other
environments yeah we got to get them out
the mud we got to do it with you know
most of these kids get you know excited
about what they see
first and just to put into perspective
for people that maybe do not know the
Florida geography where you are at
Liberty City is only what like 10 miles
from South Beach or so right yeah yeah
right across the bridge and you had
never been no we go to Hall Beach if
anybody from Miami you watching this
show you know where we go we go to hover
Beach we get our grills we get our jet
skis we go to hover we do not go to
South Beach especially if you're from
Miami you really even consider South
Beach Miami I hate when people when you
come here and you say I've been to Miami
and people be like where you went I'll
be like South no that is not you ain't C
to Miami if you went to South Beast Jack
no you did
not and that is I just think that really
is like the perspective of what you mean
by I was living in this world it wasn't
this world no I had literally all that
club live and none of that no I ain't
been to none of that not until I got it
in in the NBA and got a little change
and then it was
on so growing up to you the thing you
were going to be was I thought a
football player okay cuz we in South
Florida and that's all we do down here
in Miami is play football and then I'm a
huge Dolphin fan I mean we going back to
the Joe Robbie Stadium you know what I'm
saying people if they probably don't
even know where Joe Robbie Stadium is
nowadays there's a lot of fake dolphin
fans out here it's a lot of it's a lot
of fakes out here I don't to know who
the reals but I'm going back to Joe
Robbie Stadium Dolphin fan you know what
I'm saying Jim crash Jensen you probably
don't know who Jim Jensen is like the
real stuff so yeah so yeah I mean it's
this this is in me this is who I am man
and like I said I never stayed away from
who I was and I love my city but I ain't
never been crossed that bridge till I
got in NBA and now you are who you are a
true legend of the league you are kind
of the um you're somebody I would say
was like the leader and when people
thought about leadership in the NBA you
were a face that would come to mind what
does it take to be a good leader in this
league and is that disappearing some as
well you got to have a code like you
said earlier you got to have a code and
people got to watch you stand on them
codes no matter who it is or no matter
what it is I think the problem is people
flip codes on depending on who it is
they might check one of the guys on the
bench but they won't say nothing to the
Superstar that's when your teammates
lose respect for you that's when they
will not follow you that's when they see
through you can't do that you got to
have a code we talked about that earlier
you know what I'm saying if I got
something to say to the last on the
bench and if he's slacking and I say
something to him I can't let the number
one play on the team slack and turn my
cheek cuz they going to see that and
then they don't respect me no more and
all of a sudden my words fall on De ears
so I got to have a code I got to hold
myself accountable first coming in being
in shakee they don't want to hear that
[__] if I ain't in shakee get your old
ass out of here
OG they don't want to hear that you know
what I'm saying it don't work like that
mhm and in the league were you always
comfortable with giving that same
criticism and compliments to the
superstars that you would give to the
role players or the people on the bench
like were you always okay in that space
nah I was more so I I I I just play hard
I let my play and and and my Approach
infused the team it's like bring life to
the team like the way I approach it you
know what I'm saying and as I got a
little older you know what I'm saying I
realized that I can also impact people
with my voice you know what I'm saying
and once I realized how powerful that
was then it's like okay now how do you
impact people because everybody's
motivated impacted differently got to
get to learn people learn their families
learn their backgrounds why is he like
this why is he not like this that takes
time to spend with a person now spending
time with a person getting know a person
takes time away from what you might want
to do with your personal life or what
you have to do on your personal time how
important is it to you and you talk
about okay being a leader being able to
kind of be equal opportunity with your
criticism with your compliments M who
was your favorite or best player leader
that you've had in your
career I can't just say one give me two
I gotta
say
Shaq because he always tried to make it
about just a game he always tried to you
know he never wanted us to take it home
with us he always told us that it's just
a game enjoy it have fun and that's
something that was always hard to do and
fast forward when I got to the points
that I got to in life I realized why he
said the things he said and I was able
to kind of manifest those things and I
would say LeBron I watched Braun ride a
bike to the gym Tam 10 speed lift
weights for an hour stretch for another
hour mind you we got another two hours
before practice
start this man done done all this [__]
and practice start at 10: a. which means
he probably done started this [__] at 6
so he just different watching that
understanding what it takes to kind of
have the kind of longevity that I've had
in this league because even though I
haven't played Braun minutes I still got
to go out there and practice with them
young [__] they run they jump
they athletic they don't get no sleep
you know what I'm saying yeah I mean so
being able to have to do those things
you know made me understand that if I
wanted to continue to try to keep up
with these guys it had to be a lifestyle
you know what I'm saying all that taking
a couple weeks off in the Summertown
Hill no as soon as the season over get
your ass in the gym you got to keep
going if I stop it's over cuz I think
that is something people don't
realize basketball actually isn't the
job your body is the job yes yes and the
basketball is a symptom of you taking
care of your body always and that's what
everybody says about LeBron is number
one priority in all things is is my body
right and that
is within makes him good and making and
keeping your body right is nonstop oh
for sure and and I watch that man do
that and I said damn you know what I'm
saying he the Kan
he if he doing it he ain't got to do
that I don't think he do but he doing it
so you know what I'm saying you'll be a
fool to be around all these great guys
and all this you know magnificent talent
and not take nothing from these guys
mentally physically you know how they
getting it done how they get to where
they at how they maintain it not be a
fool not to not to learn something you
know what I'm saying that's what I tell
my guys that come behind me you know
what I'm saying you'll be a fool you
know what I'm saying not to soak up some
of this game you know what I mean MH so
before you retired you were the oldest
player in the league yes I was it is now
LeBron so nobody knows better than you
how hard it is LeBron 38 years old to be
doing what he's doing can you put into
perspective just the age and what we're
seeing and how Wild it is that we're
still seeing we probably ain't goingon
to never see that again not no time soon
we a not like that not at that level you
know what I'm saying saying you talk
about all the guys that you know played
20 some odd years and even include
myself in there you look at the combined
average I don't think we combine average
as much as what Braun averaged this his
last year he put all us together I think
we go average what Braun averaged his
last year so I mean it's not a knock on
us that's just a tribute to him you know
what he's capable of doing what he's
been able to do um and and it's not it's
not a fluke man a man work it's a
lifestyle for him you know what I'm
saying there's there's no days off even
if he's not in the gym you know what I'm
saying lifting I bet I bet sure eating
right if he and if he ain't eating right
that day he probably running it off if
he eating the wrong [__] he going to run
it off that night you know what I'm
saying he is a lifestyle and that's how
you got to live if you want to continue
to have longevity in this league man you
got to take care of your body first that
weight room all you basketball players
don't like to be in that weight room get
your ass in that weight room you trying
to be if you trying to stay away from
them injuries if you trying to have a
longlasting career that is something
that is non-negotiable that is something
that I watch Braun do that is something
that even though once again I didn't
play as much as him that is something
that was non-negotiable for me I ain't
stopped lifing weights I probably ain't
stopped lifing weights since the last
eight years from even in the summertime
when the season's over I'm still doing
the weight room before I get back on the
track before I get back in the gym the
weight room is
consistent okay so this next question
it's probably going to be hard to pick
but it is a challenge you've won three
NBA
championships which one means the most
the first one that was easy that was not
hard at all I mean because the first one
was the one where you know what I'm
saying it
was I think that was the first when I
kind of defined how my career was going
to go you know what I'm saying you don't
get to pick and choose the moments you
just got to be ready for them you know
what I'm saying Dirk and whiskey with t
people ass up in that playoff series man
tow he told San Antonio ass up told OKC
ass up and I was next on the list I was
I remember sitting that ho with my
homeboys and they looking at me like boy
your ass boy and I'm looking that D like
yeah okay because I know I got to come
home and I know they ain't going they
ain't going to lay off so now now it's
person
you know now it's personal I think you
know what I'm saying that series could
have went another way and I think youon
has career could have probably went
another
way being able to be prepared in the
moments and to be able to seize the
moments and shineing the moments a lot
of times that's how players careers are
defined you know what I'm saying it
might not be the 20 years that I played
it might be the moments that I had in
those 20 years that people might Define
me at and in that
moment [__] youon hasm stood up in the
paint you know what I'm saying and I
think that moment kind of defined how my
career was going to go did you realize
how defining it was in the moment or did
you realize it later on later I didn't
realize in the moment in the moment I
could I could be honest now I was crying
I a little emotional you know what I'm
saying I tell people with champagne in
my eye but yeah I got a little emotional
you know what I'm saying I carried a lot
undrafted you know what I'm saying and
um playing for the City of Miami born in
raised um and then stepping in a
situation where obviously like I said
you know I really wasn't given much of a
chance you know I read the paper you
know what I'm saying I don't pay
attention to what people say but I damn
sure hear them you know what I mean and
I've had this thing where I use
everything I use everything people say I
use everything people do um and there
was just so much emotions built up in
that series because you know how y'all
do y'all do the little layouts y'all do
the little matchups this person against
this person point guard Point God
shooting God shooting God small forward
small forward oh power forward this
ain't even this ain't even this ain't
even a fair match up okay keep going
with that [__] media y'all keep it up
I'm just sitting here eating eating it
up eating it up and my homeboy feeding
it to me boy you gonna te your ass up
now now I'm eating and my homeboy keep
feeding me now so now when I get in
there it's
like it's like lock me and Dirk in the
room and I don't give a damn I'm coming
out for 48 minutes you lock Us in the
room and I don't give a damn what
happened happen I got to be the one that
come out that room and that was the
mentality and did you feel like after
that even just you were received
differently did it feel like that to you
yeah yeah I mean I was able to bring a
championship back to the city um yeah
definitely received differently
definitely looked at differently you
know what I'm saying I ain't going to
lie I'm a 66 six7 and six7 power forward
I you know what I'm saying if I listen
to the analytic they I call them atics
they say analytics if I listen to the
atics a 66 and a half power forward
should not be winning a championship you
know what I'm saying so yeah I was
looked at differently I was perceived
differently you know what I'm saying and
and you know I think that's when it kind
of been the the Prince of the City kind
of like took his little name and you
know I gotta get trick the May Luke the
king you know what I'm saying Ross the
Boss yeah and I'm the Prince and that's
kind of how that went that's amazing I
mean and correct me if I'm wrong but you
know as I'm hearing you talk about about
this you're talking about you know
matching up with der what people were
saying but the confidence that you had
it doesn't sound like to me you've ever
experienced a lot of doubt about
yourself is that true or
no if I did once somebody else doubted
me it pissed me off I can doubt myself
you can't do that I could talk [__]
about myself you can't do that I could
feel a way about myself you can't do
that so when I did have doubt all I had
to do is listen to somebody else say
some [__] about me I ain't like and it
worked like a it changed everything I
felt it changed everything I was
thinking it it didn't matter anymore cuz
I'm going to prove you wrong I'm going
prove your ass wrong no matter what I
got to
do I love that because if that was your
mission you accomplish that yeah I
everybody and I mean this you have
created this for yourself and you have a
name in this league that forever rings
out you are a very specific person in
the ecosystem of the NBA
and I think that accomplishing something
like that is actually a lot harder than
winning a championship it's a lot harder
than being like one of the greats thank
you we know what this league is like and
the politics of it and the personalities
how people receive things all these
things so for you to be as solid in it
and to have planted such a flag in it I
think above all else is probably the
thing that you maybe should make to take
the most
pride in is it yeah you're right you're
right you're right you're right I mean
to be able to be to be able to to be
respected like I said by all generations
yeah and because I said it's one thing
to be respected by the guys you played
with and they know you but it's a whole
another thing to be respected by this
next Generation that didn't play with
you don't know you as well because once
again they can see through it they can
see the fake [__] they can see the
[__] you can't lie to them you can't
sell it to them you know what I'm saying
and and they ain't buying it they don't
have to you 43 years old whether I
listen to you or not I'm going still get
my money you know what I'm saying
absolutely they don't have to so if they
see through your [__] they will
dismiss you and move on you know what
I'm saying so you either figure out how
to be a asset or they don't they they
they ain't listening to me so first
things first hold myself accountable
come in in shape before you tell
somebody else to be in shape get your
old ass in shape make sure your old ass
stay in shape
absolutely I want to talk about the heat
a little bit Let's Do It um so after the
Eastern Conference Finals last
season SPO and Bam were on the stage and
Bam was like I was so excited because
you know SPO had us watch this movie and
it got us hype what was the movie I
can't tell nobody oh my goodness I'm not
telling nobody I'm not telling nobody
what that movie was but just understand
face was like just understand
everything we might anything we watch
anything we talk about it's about
staying connected through everything
it's about staying connected because
that's our superpowers our connection
okay so that is probably all will ever
find out that's all you going get about
this movie that's all you gonna get from
me I I'm like I one day it might be I
tell you one thing it wasn't a movie it
was a documentary I give you that okay
we y'all watch the doc learned about
staying connected through watching that
doc I don't know if it's going to be two
years 5 years 10 years did you see I'm
going to figure out why y'all watch did
you see SM face when bam said that
that's said I got to know I got to
know he's looking at him like do not say
it and then Bam's thinking why did I
even mention this movie that was for the
team did y'all get on him after for
mentioning it yeah we all just laughed
about spo's face the look on SP face
when B mentioned that I'm like we yeah
we gotta get we got to get people on the
case I got to find out what this
documentary is I'm trying to I'm trying
to get connected that was it that was
supposed to stay in
house well you know the Miami Heat
though just generally obviously you talk
a lot about culture what it means to be
a Miami Heat player but I actually
believe that this likely will stay in
house like this is an organization where
you all do keep things go to the best it
is about being connected in this
Brotherhood that exists yes it it is a
th% I mean if you look at the success
we've been able to have we've been the
more connected team you know what I'm
saying I think what people start to
realize that all you Athletics
and just think that you can write down
on paper what a championship team should
look like and then you GNA poof and they
gonna be in the
championship once you do it every year
you go do it again this year you'll do
it again next year you do it every year
but once they realize that that is not
the
true ingredients to winning a team you
can have talent you can have coaching
you can draw that [__] up like
Lombardi if the guys are not connected
if they don't
believe if you ain't got got some
dogs you ain't it's not happening what
gives you the confidence that bam can be
that culture carrier for the Miami Heat
cuz I watched him I seen him with my own
eyes you know what I'm saying I've seen
who he came in and who he was you know
being a backup to Assan coming off the
bench to being an Allstar to being an
Olympian you know what I'm saying to
being a leader you know on both ends of
the floor you know what I'm saying now
we talking about the game of basketball
we talking about guys that are two-way
players how many guys actually do that
and he's one that does it with the best
of them you know what I'm saying I think
the success that Miami Heat has had over
the last four years um you don't have
that success without bam now obviously
everybody understands what playoff Jimmy
does and how great Jimmy is and we
understand how great hero is with the
six man of the year but the one
consistent piece that has not been
injured they got injured once and I got
to chance to play I actually played well
too but the one consistent piece that
doesn't get injured must the one
consistent piece that you know keeps
that engine going offensively and
defensively is Bam and that's how I know
because we've been so successful and he
might not get the credit that is due
because we got guys that score a lot
more points and that's what people like
that's pretty that's cute um but the one
consistent piece that has kept that [__]
together is Bam Bam's the gamer yes sir
yes sir yes sir so last season during
the Eastern Conference Finals I was
texting Jimmy about the game and he said
Taylor I'm the best basketball player in
the world I spoke to him a few weeks ago
he said I'm still the best basketball
player in the world I think what people
don't understand is Jimmy means that and
believes that when he says that oh for
sure he yeah he know I play listen I
just went just played against Jimmy the
other day so every day last year on home
games Jimmy and I played one-on-one and
you might not believe this I still got a
little something in the tank I went and
played the other day with him now with
that being said the shots that Jimmy
Butler make are not
normal this is what I'm saying to you
and if somebody keeps making them then
you start believing it's not luck
anymore you know what I'm saying so I've
seen Jimmy make shots on me repeti
repeatedly am I saying this [__] like
I've seen Jimmy make shots on me that
people don't make and he keeps making
them the degree of difficulty on the
shots that he's making how he is
creating space to get to these shots
there that is something different
because I've done the same thing with
Dwayne I've played one-onone with Dwayne
I've played one-onone with LeBron I've
played one-on-one with Joe Johnson and
some of the greatest ISO one-onone
players in the league now I've played
one-onone with Jimmy you know what I'm
saying so I've seen the difference now
that's not to say that Jimmy's better
than those guys but Jimmy damire might
be one of the smartest one out of those
guys Jimmy is smart as hell he
understands how to get his shot off he
understands how to get you to switch
your pivot feet so he can attack one leg
so he can counter you he understands how
to get to the free throw line now mind
you you're thinking about all this stuff
as you're guarding Jimmy and then he
just shoot it in your face because you
got your hands down yep you know what
I'm saying so it's just so much that
comes in the play when you have to guard
a Jimmy Butler especially for 48 minutes
so I think the thing with Jimmy and I'm
I'm trying to think of the right way to
word this like we obviously all know how
great Jimmy is when he gets to the
postseason we call him playoff Jimmy we
applaud these performances in the ways
that he is able to will his team to a
win or to you know conference title
whatever the case may be
but sometimes I feel like in some ways
the playoff Jimmy moniker has hurt him
amongst NBA fans because they are
feeling like they're only seeing it in
the playoffs now whether that's true or
not they're not understanding that it's
still the ability that he can turn this
on when it needs to be turned on do you
think that people are sort of
misunderstanding Jimmy's game because of
the focus that is always on Jimmy in the
postseason does that make sense yeah it
makesense well one thing I'm G say about
people at home Jimmy Butler is the
ultimate competitor I think I think
honestly I think Jimmy love competition
more than basketball yeah Spades Chinese
doino whatever it is Jimmy want to smoke
yeah you know what I'm saying so Jimmy
is the ultimate competitor if Jimmy
could play all 80 I'm retired 82 84 how
many if Jimmy could play all 82 games 84
how many it is I don't play no more but
if he could play all them games he would
play them he would play them his body
just not doesn't allow we Al talking
about another guy who plays both ends of
the basketball court two-way player he
is not taking a break on the defensive
end he's most likely going to be
guarding the best offensive player nine
times out of 10 between him and Bam so
we talking about a guy who puts a lot on
his body mentally physically and
emotionally so yes there are times where
Jimmy Butler has to take a seat you know
what I'm saying and understand you know
be smart about it um that's just how it
goes you know what I'm saying I've never
been a guy who's been asked to do so
much offensively and defensively you
know what I'm saying so I don't know how
that might feel but I can imagine you
know what I'm saying and when he does
step out on the floor he leaves it on
the floor I have no I have no quarrels
about what Jimmy brings when he suits up
absolutely you know what I'm saying so I
understand that you can't pour from
empty cup sometimes you got to refill
his cup and I respect that for sure were
you a buet guy I do a little Bay just I
do a little just a little bit a little
Bay back in the day you Los a little
money on Bay yeah my business manager
over there about yeah he's like he
unfortunately was a bay guy yeah them
days over I don't gamble that much no
more I don't have no time like that yeah
you gamble you you know them was hours
we used to play for hours and the plane
rides and just everything and then it's
like somebody challenge you to the game
you got to say yeah then you land
depending on how good the game is you
keep it going you know what I'm saying I
ain't got time to spend that kind of
money no more best you don't need to
tell me the the price or anything but
just best Bay game you've been a part of
man I seen somebody lose one night and
somebody yell I'm about to go bu a
truck
that's how much it was that's how much
it was yeah y'all take it seriously no I
wasn't in that game I had no folded
M I'm done I had no folded M I love that
uh did you did you think that Dame was
coming to Miami um I thought it was
possible you know once he said he wanted
to come to Miami I thought it was
possible you know what I'm saying but I
think one thing about us is we don't
worry about who we don't have and what
we don't have we only wor about who's in
the locker room and what we got to do so
if he would have came you know what I'm
saying welcome but you know what I'm
saying we wasn't tripping you know what
I'm saying it's just it's part of the
business but Dame is a a hell of a
player I like Dame I'm saying I really
do like Dame so who wouldn't want Dame
Li but you know what I'm saying at the
end of the day we don't really focus on
what we don't have and who we don't have
yeah and you everything moves you keep
moving yeah and we gonna be fine I still
expect us to win the East yeah yes I do
oh I I know you all always believe that
yes I do yeah I do you say you are you
mean you don't I uh well first off I'm a
h let me interview you I'm a Hawks fan
so I all and I'm always wrong that we're
gonna so I can say always think we're
gonna Asian knows I said it every year
it never happen so yeah but hey like at
least I'm Southern so don't hold it
against me yeah exactly I still expect
the East to go through Miami you know
I'm saying I I don't care what's on
paper you know what I'm saying I really
don't the game got to be played in
between lies now I will say the reason I
am in no way doubting the thing that
you're saying is because you all have
shown that it will work because you guys
will yourself to these places so it's
not that I think it's a it would be a
surprise right so let me ask you a
question okay here we why every year is
it
about New York or Brooklyn or Philly or
Boston and oh Miami's over there too why
why is it always like that
so I don't know the exact answer to that
I feel like I don't necessarily do the
projections in that way but I think that
the simple answer and probably the most
truthful answer is that people pay
attention to those teams because of
their cities because of their markets
because of the one big name guy that's
on that team I don't think I agree that
people bring New York into it though I
don't think people ever say that New
York is going to be the favorite that's
one of the ones that you said not the
favorites but they always pick these
teams over us yeah that is true how the
atheltics that's actually we're gonna
have to you know we're the atics we're
gonna pull up NBA Twitter live because I
did not pick those teams over y'all I
put y'all in it I'll pull up my rankings
okay cool I'm just trying to figure out
how they keep getting the I mean thank
you because we use it we appreciate
y'all keep doing it y'all ain't learned
yet but damn yeah but it's you know a
lot of it too is just what I've sort of
learned about being in the media is a
narrative will always take over
sometimes it takes
one person saying it for everyone to say
that is likely what's going to happen
because the more you're fed something
over and over and over the more players
that you're seeing over and over and
over you tend to believe that means that
they are the best people equate exposure
to the greatness if that makes sense I
understand but really it's just this is
who we're saying so it's who we're
talking about okay but I think also you
all I think you all kind of like that
people don't pick
you like I think you you internalize
that in some ways and in some ways I
think it actually does help that you
don't get picked we we use it yeah
exactly so you know what you're welcome
we use we we use everything we use
everything you are welcome that is my
response to that well I told you how I
am I mean if I don't feel a way about
myself and if I hear somebody else say
it they not allowed to say that yeah you
know what I'm saying as soon as they say
it now we pissed yeah yeah now we got to
prove him wrong now we got to prove you
wrong um another nugget that I really
liked when I was listening to your
interview that you did with the pivot is
you were talking about when Braun and
dwade and Bosch were here they took less
money for you to be on the team what did
you learn about those three guys in that
moment making that decision how
important winning a championship was to
them those guys didn't know me Dwayne
knew me obviously but LeBron didn't know
me and Chris didn't know me but the fact
that they thought that I W could help
them get to that point of winning the
championship and two it was that
important that they would sacrifice
Millions ofar
to get that for somebody they don't even
know haven't had a conversation with
it's not like we sat down and had dinner
and we like okay we going to do this I
was a part of the dinner you know with
with BR you know D and CV had dinner I
wasn't a part of the dinner so for those
guys to make that decision on the Fly
you know what I'm saying because they
didn't have much time to think about it
because I was on my way out Jack you
know I was on my way out Jack you know
I'm saying so those guys to make that
decision on a fly and to be able to just
break a little bit of bread off of me
you know what I'm saying I just want to
make sure one you know you know what I'm
saying I appreciate it and two I'm make
sure they get their money's worth
absolutely a few more for you I do want
to talk a little about a little bit
about uh retirement yes um I know the
moment that you announced you were
retiring but when was the moment that
you knew that it was time to
retire um the year before my last year I
lost my pops that's when I knew I was
definitely done you know what I'm saying
we were supposed to ride out together
you know I mean my last year we was
going to spend a lot of time together we
he was going to travel with me you know
what I'm saying do a lot of things my
pops was my best friend so when you
think about it you know what I'm saying
a lot of the guys that I played with
either retired or moved on to play
somewhere else so I wasn't spending much
time with my teammates you know what I'm
saying outside of doing the things they
want to do so many so much damn what the
damn thing they play it's only so much
oh yeah like PS Xbox whatever playing
that damn thing in the dog and like it's
only so much that I could do so outside
of you know what I'm saying my free time
with my teammates I us to spend a lot of
time with my dad like I said watching
the dolphin games you know what I'm
saying we listen to eyes of the brothers
just be chilling so you know
um that was that was that you know that
that was different you know what I'm
saying losing losing my pops
and change things you know what I'm
saying it's get a little emotional think
about my pops but I missed them you know
what I'm saying so you know when I
didn't have him around um kind of lose
my train of thought think about my pops
it's okay so back the question up no no
it's it's all good I was yeah I was I
was just talking about when you knew
that it was time to retire and I I do
understand yeah I miss why you feel that
way yeah so my pops man it was it was it
was it was time to retire because I
didn't have my Pops from the day I
stepped on the basketball court that man
watched me he coached me he cheered for
me you know what I'm saying and when I
didn't have him watching when I didn't
have him coaching when I have them
cheering it just wasn't the same you
know what I'm saying I wasn't the same I
was able to still give what I needed to
give to other people but nobody was
really giv to me you know what I'm
saying like I said remember I tell you
came P from empty cup my pops was my
biggest Chader my pops was my biggest
fan you know what I'm saying so even
though I wasn't playing that much I
would sit on the bench or whatever the
situation may be and pouring to 15 other
guys you know what I'm saying my pops
was always pouring into me so when I
lost the person I was pouring into me it
was kind of time to step away from it it
changed what the game was yeah it
changed what the game was you know what
I'm saying I just like I said my Pops
from the day I stepped on the basketball
court he was there with me so when I
lost him and he wasn't going to be a
part of my last year it changed kind of
what the last year meant to me and it it
kind of changed a little bit of the
journey but I was still
thankful but yeah that it was time yeah
no I I understand pH you can get as
emotional as you need that that is
totally fine my mom um she lost both her
parents very close together and one
thing she always would say is that it
never gets easier it just gets more real
to you yeah and so I I totally empathize
with that and I'm so sorry for your loss
yeah it was different the game just just
it wasn't the same you know I'm saying I
still love the game I still love
impacting the people around me I still
love everything that I was doing but I
just wasn't getting the same feelings
you know what I'm saying that I used to
get so yeah it was time did that change
how happy the game made
you um yeah winning winning always make
me happy it was no better feeling than
holding up that trophy in Boston last
year yeah it's Conference Finals you
know what I'm saying that makes you feel
good you know what I'm saying winning
games seven on the
road um obviously you know we didn't get
it done in Denver um but you know just
the Gratitude of you know getting that
far my last year you know what I'm
saying it made it worth it you know what
I mean it made it it made it all worth
it win and cure is everything yeah
winning cures everything for sure he I
know that is absolutely true yes winning
cures everything so yes winning it cures
it all mhm so how have you just overall
dealt with the transition of being a
retired player I mean for most of your
life you were doing one thing I haven't
stopped staying busy I still get up and
work out every morning I worked out this
morning I hit the ground running
um business is my passion now you know
what I'm saying I got my hands on a lot
of pots I call myself the octopus
Hustler you know what I'm saying just I
might take that yeah I just like to call
myself the octopus Hustler I mean what
what what you want like what you need
what the city need you know what I'm
saying we got affordable housing you
know what I'm saying we all understand
you know what I'm saying the Gap right
now with the housing situation out here
I can get into the number but they
probably don't want to hear them but
right now you know what I'm saying
annually people making like 48 50,000 in
South Florida it takes 100 110,000 to
rent comfortably so now we trying to
bridge the gap of housing you know what
I'm saying um mental health you know
what I'm saying I got a mental health
project and facility that we got coming
up you know what I'm saying it should be
done
um jobs got Starbucks got Einstein it's
got Subway um medical marijuana I'm the
part of the flowery you know I'm saying
I tell all my homeboys you should not be
going to jail for weed in 2023 dog I do
not want you to be worried about nobody
getting behind you and you nervous we is
too old for that and it is now legal
brother go get your paperwork you know
what I'm saying so for me um just
business is my passion man I'm all over
the place with that I love it um TV yes
I I seen the spots so we've got a star
folks little TV little TV you know what
I'm saying my boy Dwayne told me a long
time ago he said man you know when you
think about it you should probably think
about doing little TVs like you got
knowledge of the game you got a good
personality you know what I'm saying you
might enjoy it so that was something
that he told me a long time ago and you
know for one thing about you know I'm
saying my boy Dwayne like you know what
I mean we the conversations we have are
so like different from like what we used
to talk about you know what I'm saying
now it's about business now it's about
life now it's about adulthood you know
what I'm saying encouraging conversation
so he he put me on TV a long time ago
and told me I something I should look
into I love that and and Dwayne is
another like Elder Statesman of the
league you know so it's absolutely a
match made in heaven uh speaking of
business I know you said you want to one
day be some sort of owner of the heat
what conversations have you had with you
know Pat Riley about about that goal of
yours yeah we still having them it's a
lot of paperwork it's a lot of layers to
that you know what I'm saying it's not
easy you know what I'm saying but you
know the I wouldn't say so much Pat it'
be Mickey and and Nick um but they're
open it's a conversation that we're
having um and you know when I talk about
you know not really you know having like
dreams how could you dream about sitting
here having a conversation about being
an owner with the Mi he you can't dream
that as a kid you know what I'm saying
those are things that I I wouldn't have
been able to process of even dreaming so
like I said I just kept my head down and
just worked and just once I achieve one
thing okay damn what else I could do if
I push what else I could do if I try
what else I I could do you know what I'm
saying I've learned a lot you know what
I'm saying what I can do if I just put
myself in the right position and handle
my business the right way yeah you know
what I'm saying so
um that's on the table when we working
on it and hopefully it'll happen soon
sooner than later but it's it's it's
it's an opportunity for sure absolutely
one thing that is very clear to me and
that I really like is sort of a common
threat in your life is that you are open
to your goals constantly changing yeah
and you understand that like I said even
though the world might be here your
world gets like this but then you see
that the world can still get bigger PIV
and bigger pivot Life For Me has been
and I don't hate to say it cuz that's
them Boy show but pivot y'all boy got a
hell of a show but life has been how you
pivot man how can you pivot cuz if you
think you just going to draw this map
and say I want life to go like this this
this this and I'm gonna be here it ain't
going like that you know what I'm saying
it ain't going like that I'm sorry to
tell you but the American dream of the
house the dog you get your degree and
you go to school and you get the four Cs
and all that no go to school your ass
gonna probably be in Deb so all this
stuff that we was told is what's the
American dream to make us happy n bro
what's your definition of happiness you
got to find that out yourself you got to
walk your path and see what makes you
happy what don't make you happy and you
got to live in your truth to get to your
happiness man but for
me nah man my happiness ain't been what
people told me it was going to be I had
to figure it out and find it myself
because if I listen to what people told
me I wouldn't be happy and I wouldn't be
here yeah absolutely and you do have to
Pivot and no we we love the pivot here
I've been on the show too those guys are
great go Gator channing's a mess
chanting go Gator yeah Ryan love what
you doing they're they're great I I was
on that show and I had a beautiful time
um I read that you have a lot of jerseys
around your house MJ D Marino a bunch of
people what's your favorite Jersey and
which Jersey has the best story about
how it was
acquired oh wow that's a great
question my favorite
Jersey I would probably have to say my
favorite Jersey would
[Music]
be that's a great question
who put why did you put my favorite
Jersey would have to be my my my uh
Dwayne Dwayne gave me his Olympic jersey
I Dwayne weight Olympic
jersey and that was and out of all the
jerseys I have obviously you know the
Olympics is a a different level you know
what I'm saying and that's something
that you know I I've never been able to
experience I never obviously will be
able to experience that but you know
what I'm saying at that point in his
life you know what I'm saying to be
representing the country you know what
I'm saying to be on that platform for
him and to be one of the you know Chosen
Few to represent that country and to
come back with that Jersey and I'm sure
you don't have a lot of those you know
what I'm saying and to bring back one of
those jerseys and the signing to give it
to me I probably have to say that's
probably one of the more prized
possessions because it could have been
anybody he could have gave that Jersey
too yeah you know what I'm saying
Olympic jersey um but he gave it to me
so I would have say that's probably one
of my more you know prize prize
possessions as far as Jersey wise and
then my dam
Marino anything Dolphins Dan Marino Mar
Clayton super duper I got all those
Jersey anything Dolphins is like the top
of the list yeah and all them the same
no no man is above each other even
though Dan Marino was the king but guy I
put dup and Clayton right next to him
amazing oh wait I want to talk about the
dagers really quick because that's a
beautiful Story how did it come into
your possession why do you think he gave
it to you what was his you know
reasoning when he presented it well I
tried to buy it at an
auction and I bid it for it and when it
was time for me to pay he said nah he
wouldn't take my money said your money's
no good here wow so uh you know I
appreciate my boy for doing that but I
bid it for it I bid it for it at auction
um for one of his charity events and
then when he realized that I was the one
who wanted charity he wouldn't take my
money he just signed and told me he
wanted me to have it that's beautiful
any message or just the signature on it
uh I think it's like to the realest
[__] I know or some [__] like that said
y abely real talk you asked that's what
was on it I think is what it really I
love it that's what was no that's
beautiful and that is like an iconic
Jersey
that's really great well last one for
you know speaking of jerseys it's been
you know said that your jersey is going
to be retired it's going to be right
there when you when people look up in
the raap rafters and see your jersey
what do you want them to feel
uh when you look up in the Raptors and
see my jersey what do you
feel
ah
[__] one of the realest I guess to ever
put on a Heat jersey one of the hardest
working you feel
the when you look up there you the DNA
the culture you know what I'm saying I
think every guy has taken it and kind of
made it better so it was zo and then you
know you see me now and I made it a
little better and until bam or he hangs
his jersey up there I'm going be the one
that's kind of the guy who made it what
it is right now you know what I'm saying
so when you look up at that Jersey
you're going to see the bearer of the
culture of the DNA for the Miami Heat
for a long ass time for a long ass time
when you look at that Jersey and the
rafters how will you
feel accomplished finally because I
don't never let myself really look at my
accomplishments I kind of like I said
always keep my head down one I
accomplish one thing I go for something
else once you get up there I'm going
finally exhale and say okay you did all
right for yourself boy but until then
like I said I just been keeping my head
down working but once it get up there
I'm going look back and I'm going
finally reflect cuz I don't reflect
often I'm not much a reflection type
person you know what I'm saying I'm more
of a person that gets up in the morning
and I kind of do my little words of
affirmation and I move forward I ain't I
ain't looking back too much you know
what I'm saying but when I when no
Jersey go up there I'll reflect I'll
look back good you deserve to I'll allow
myself that yeah no I love that you
deserve to Exhale you've done a lot and
you were a pleasure this was beautiful
thank you so much you for me absolutely
[Music]
anytime